(upbeat music)
There is no idealistic future,
you know where it's just gonna,
it's gonna all be right
and we're just gonna be happy you know?
Happiness isn't something, we're not a victim of it.
It doesn't just happen to us, you know?
It's happening all the time
and it's our ability to see it and recognize it.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
My guest today is Thomas Rivers Puzey
or Tommy Rivs to his friends, to his family
and his many, many fans across the world.
Tommy is a poet of endurance,
he's a philosopher of the human spirit,
as well as a highly credentialed elite marathoner
and ultra runner with many victories
and accolades to his name,
as well as being a man universally beloved
for his kindness and generosity of spirit.
As some of you may know, in the summer of 2020,
Tommy fell gravely ill with an extremely rare
and advanced form of lung cancer
that very nearly killed him.
And most likely would have killed almost anyone else.
But Rivs isn't just anyone,
Rivs is Rivs, he did survive.
And he's here today to share his perspective,
his wisdom his experience.
It's a soulful and at times emotional conversation,
it's a celebration of the human spirit.
This miracle that is life itself,
and a really powerful reminder that things like gratitude,
positivity, service, community, and love,
mostly love are what are most important.
Rivs is an exemplary human,
he is a quiet and introspective mentor to many,
and really an example to so many more human.
I personally aspire to emulate who reports himself with
an admirable degree of dignity,
grace of humility and generosity of spirit.
A quick note, before we begin,
this conversation was actually recorded a couple months ago
on October 13th and thus prior to Tommy's most recent
and perhaps most courageous
and astonishing endurance feet today.
One mere year from having to actually relearn
how to even walk,
Tommy just completed the New York city marathon.
It took him over nine agonizing hours,
which is seven hours longer than his 218-PR,
but that nine hours, was globally celebrated the world over
and really introduced this humble and extraordinary man
to people all across the world,
including a wonderful must read profile
in the New York Times that
I will link up and description below.
It's an honor to help share Tommy's story.
It's a story I think will prove impactful for you.
So without further ado, this is me and Tommy Rivs.
But we're in a little slice of heaven out here,
it's a beautiful day, you're here.
We're so delighted you're here.
Everybody here is so happy to see you and-
Thanks man.
I'm excited to talk to you, man.
I mean, I guess the first thing is like, how are you?
Like, how do you feel today?
Like, how are you doing?
I'm sure we get that question constantly?
(Rich laughs)
No, it's good.
Gosh, I'm stoked to be here.
I mean, just,
(Tommy sighs)
yeah, I'm just stocked that I'm just still around, you know?
Yeah.
I mean, I really I'm.
Like, it's a good question because
it's a good reminder to me,
just to recenter myself,
and helped me realize that
that it's like, this is,
couldn't be better than this,
there's no way that it can be any better.
I mean, it's,
(Tommy chuckles)
yeah, I think about that a lot
and it's,
as good as I could possibly ever hope
that life would be,
and just being able to see that right now and recognize it.
Yeah, that's,
I guess that's just kinda where I'm at,
just.
You seem like somebody who's always had a firm grip,
on gratitude.
You know when I think about you,
I think about grace and humility
and somebody who's always more concerned
with how other people are doing than yourself,
but to be able to kind of hold onto that
or capture that sense of gratitude
with everything that you've endured and continue to endure.
I mean, that's really remarkable.
Like how do you, how do you account for that?
Is it your natural disposition?
Is it a practice you must have your dark moments
with all of this, of course.
The last year and a half or so,
of getting sick and everything?
Yeah, yeah, there's definitely been some,
(Tommy clears throat)
excuse me.
There's been some hard times-
Yeah.
To say the least-
A few.
Yeah.
You know I see it, I guess as a,
it goes back to just these basic,
I guess, these basic ideas
that we learned in endurance athletics,
that you focus on what you can control,
that you have a certain amount of energy,
emotional energy, physical energy, mental energy,
spiritual energy, it all comes from the same well.
And that,
you know you can only control a certain amount of that.
And I guess, focusing and allocating those resources
towards something that I actually have
the ability to affect,
and,
you can affect your work ethic
and you can affect your attitude.
Those are kind of-
It's pretty much it, right?
Yeah, exactly.
And so,
(Tommy clears throat)
I guess there's a sense of,
I think about how often you, waste energy,
by wishing things were,
a certain way, when they aren't.
Mhmh.
And I guess gratitude just comes as a natural,
I guess a natural response to just recognizing that
you do have control over certain things, you know?
Yeah.
And,
yeah.
(Tommy chuckles)
Yeah, that's a-
I know that,
at some point, I don't know whether you wrote it,
or your wife Steph wrote it,
but she conveyed to you this idea when you were kind of
in the thick of,
going through what you've endured,
this idea of applying what you learned
through your lifestyle and your training
to navigating like this next chapter.
Like, this is what endurance sports is,
it's about endurance for life, right?
Like you just kind of mentioned that,
the idea that, you're out there testing yourself,
putting yourself, in difficult situations,
trying to, figure out where the edge of that envelope is.
And this is just a more macro version of that.
Like as a means of kind of reframing your relationship with
the illness to help kind of give you, or like buttress,
your kind of emotional approach to how you deal with it.
Yeah, yeah definitely.
I feel like,
yeah, like everything that
and I think that the reason that we're drawn to,
endurance athletics is because it serves as a,
almost as a skill building experience so that we can then
take what we learn the skills and the strengths,
and then apply it to actual real life, right?
And then we're constantly reminding ourselves,
day after day, after day,
that we're in charge
that we're not just this miserable creature,
that's just gonna stay in bed and,
just constantly seek comfort,
that we can rise up above,
and you kind of remind ourselves that like,
we're capable of,
(Tommy chuckles)
getting out of bed when the alarm goes off,
before the sun comes up and putting in the work,
day after day after day.
And, then when,
you're faced with challenges in,
personal life or daily life,
it just becomes second nature
those habits that you create,
the skills that you develop in those strengths.
Gosh and I'd like to say that,
I was prepared for all of this and,
that there was some greater, deeper meaning
behind all of it and,
but man when you're in it
and I'm still in it,
you're just trying to,
(Tommy chuckles)
just trying to keep your head above water.
How could you possibly be prepared for it?
I mean, it's the unimaginable thing.
It's the thing that you could have never predicted.
And I think, as far as,
endurance sports preparing you for other life challenges,
certainly that's true.
But when it's just you in the road or you in the trail,
there's kind of a limited number of variables, right?
And you do have control over how you comport yourself,
you're focused on the breath.
You're trying to get from A to B and there is,
there is an experiential aspect of that,
but there's also a result oriented aspect.
Like I'm trying to get to this destination
or I'm working towards a certain goal
and life's just messy,
compared to that, right?
There's other people involved there's personalities,
there's expectations, it's infinitely more complicated.
Right, yeah.
It's,
(Tommy chuckles)
yeah.
I mean to be,
to be completely candid with all of it,
it's all been,
just a blur, honestly, all of it,
and Steph, my wife Steph she's done,
she's helped me out in a way that,
well she's helped me out in so many ways.
And part of it is, that she's,
she's been the one that shouldered all of the,
knowledge about all of this, you know?
She's been there with me from the very beginning,
as often as she was allowed to be there.
And,
I think about she balanced these two,
these two simultaneous truths,
that might seem as though they're,
contradictory.
And the one truth was,
she held on to all of the,
the diagnostic,
prognosis type, scientific medical information.
She understood, what the research said,
what the data said,
what the likelihood of outcome and survival
when all of that was.
At the same time she held,
what would seem like an opposing truth,
which was that this was,
it was possible to survive this.
And,
she was able to communicate both of those
to me in a way that,
she carried the weight of all of it.
Mhmh.
But was able to communicate to me,
"Yes, this is serious,
but, you're gonna get through it.
There's a process,
there are some things that you're gonna have to do
that we're gonna have to do
to be able to get to the other side of this,
but it's just simply a matter of checking these boxes
and doing it.
And then when you're done,
you'll be over this, you'll survive this you'll be whole,
you'll be well again."
And,
I think that,
(Tommy chuckles)
because of that, there's never been a time throughout this,
that I didn't actually believe that I would survive.
Mhmh.
So, she was somewhat circumspect with you,
in terms of like,
the dire details of what you were facing.
Yeah, she held all that
and,
she didn't actually share much of that with me.
Aha.
And I actually,
I've done my best to try,
to not find out.
(Tommy chuckles)
Right.
Those types of, I guess, the statistics
and things like that.
Somebody that was just a passive observer of,
the things that she wrote and the things that were,
made public, knows more about,
the details of all of this,
than I think I even do.
And I, lot of what I've learned is just stuff
that I've stumbled upon accidentally,
and I'll start to read it, I'll start to see it
and I'll think, "Oh, gosh."
'Cause you were unconscious through,
the great majority, of a lot of this.
So it was Steph and Jacob,
who made this decision to be very transparent
about everything that was going on.
And because so many people love you,
everybody was hanging on the edge of their seat,
wanting to know the details and,
eager to learn how you were doing on a daily basis.
And, you know they were like every single day,
like I would log in and see how you were doing.
And they would have reports and prognoses and all the like,
meanwhile, you're,
you're the one who's enduring it,
but you're not conscious to,
(Rich laughs)
really have to deal with the,
the emotional,
pressure of what that entail.
Sure, yeah.
I, yeah,
I haven't read any of it.
Yeah.
I really haven't.
I mean, I've seen some of it
and I've read enough to realize,
I don't want to read this yet.
You know and Steph has the whole time,
she's asked, well
I'll just have questions on how did I get this scar,
how did I get this scar, this scar, this scar, this scar,
where did these scars come from?
And she's like, "What do you want me to tell you?"
And I'm like, "Actually no, I'd rather not know."
And your daughter,
you have three daughters, right?
Yeah three girls.
I mean they're old enough,
to go online and read this stuff, right?
I mean, what is their awareness around?
I mean, the oldest one, I guess she could be,
she's way more into like bugs and frogs and stuff like that.
Then, getting online and reading about stuff.
Keep it that way.
Yeah, exactly, you know she's,
I don't think that,
I think that if,
well, one thing that I think that hopefully
we've done right with all this,
is try to shield them from,
just the spectacle of it you know?
And not let it become something that,
(Tommy clears throat)
their identity is reduced to,
you know at school or with,
Flagstaff's a small town and trying to,
help them understand like,
the seriousness of the situation, but not have it become a,
I guess just not a spectacle, you know?
And,
yeah,
and so, a lot of it is still,
to be determined, you know?
This is a,
I've got to be,
grateful for each,
each day that I have to be here but at the same time,
recognizing that this is still,
this is still an ongoing thing.
Yeah, so you're in remission right now,
but there's this looming threat that
it could come back at any time.
Right yeah.
But if you get through a certain period of time,
like a year or so then that risk reduces significantly.
Yeah, for sure, it definitely reduces it.
It's a particular type typically comes back,
until there's been,
until there's been a bone marrow transplant,
and,
it's kind of this tricky holding pattern where,
you're not given permission to land,
but you're running out a fuel, you know?
Mhmh.
And-
So are you waiting on that right now?
Are you waiting on-
So it's tricky.
It's,
so in order to,
there are so few cases,
of this particular type of cancer
that there's not a ton known about it,
but typically it comes back until,
unless there's been a bone marrow transplant
and you have to be in remission
in order to have a bone marrow transplant.
And when,
when I first went into remission,
(Tommy clears throat)
excuse me,
I think it was last January, last January,
I weighed about 95 pounds and my lungs were so scarred up.
I think it was about 20% lung functioning.
And, one of my oncologists, she said,
she sat down and had I conversation with Steph and I
and said, "We're not gonna,
we can't treat you anymore.
We're not gonna continue, we can't do any more chemo
and we also can't,
we can't give you a bone marrow transplant
because you won't, survive.
You have to be able to,
you have to have certain
I guess physical markers to be able to
even be a candidate for it,
just because,
(Tommy clears throat)
they're not gonna give you something
that they know is just a death sentence.
the chemo necessary,
to destroy all of your bone marrow so then you can receive
the transplant that's,
so toxic, that in and of itself,
a lot of times can be failing."
Right.
And so they said, "All right, this is something
that we can't do right now because,
this'll for sure 100% kill you.
And so what we got to do is basically,
you don't have cancer right now,
you're in remission right now."
That was the greatest risk at the time, you know?
A lot of this is,
just a process of looking at
what is the greatest possible risk
and trying to eliminate that,
one step at a time.
And so the cancer was no longer the risk
and the greatest risk was,
lack of lung function and technically starvation.
My body was in a state of it's called cancer cachexia,
where it's muscle wasting
and your body's unable to absorb enough nutrients
to be able to put on weight, even though it's,
being pumped through your stomach.
And so,
you're in this state,
that's completely basically starved,
you're starving to death.
Your body is just cannibalizing itself.
Exactly, yeah.
And so, you're,
that was the greatest risk at the time.
And, so they said, "Okay, let's just wait and see.
And if and when this comes back,
we'll set up a plan, we'll go through,
set up a treatment plan,
that would consist of more rounds of chemo
and to get me back into remission again,
and then, to be able to destroy,
(Tommy clears throat)
my bone marrow and then,
set me up to be able to have a transplant."
And then, and at that time,
hopefully my lungs were stronger
and my weight was up to where
I'd be able to actually survive and so-
And so right now, the goal,
I would imagine is to just try to be as healthy as you can.
Yeah.
So that you'll be able,
if and when that occurs,
you can withstand what gets thrown at you.
Yeah, exactly yeah.
And are your lungs currently at 20% still?
I don't know if-
They're improving at all
or you have a sense of that?
Yeah, it's definitely improved.
It, improves slowly though
lungs don't regenerate like liver would, you know?
And, so there's a lot of scar tissue
at like a,
at a really cellular level at the where
the gas exchange takes place.
And so,
it's difficult to get enough oxygen in,
and then it's difficult to get enough CO2 back out.
Yeah.
And I can feel it
I can sense kind of where I'm at,
just by,
you know you become really in tune with it.
It's like, when you're running at elevation
or you're, you're swimming and doing,
hypoxic breathing,
you can feel you're like,
"Okay, I got five more seconds
before the lights go out, so."
But coming down from Flag to here to sea level,
could you feel the difference, yeah.
(both laugh)
Part of what I was so stoked about to come here was like,
I'll be able to actually breathe-
Breathe a little bit better.
You know?
Yeah.
So you're breathing LA air,
so it's pretty clear out today, but.
(Rich laughs)
No, it's good.
Yeah, oxygen's is a great thing, you know?
Yeah, so,
(Tommy clears throat)
certainly a lot of people listening or watching are familiar
with the story, but there's gonna be,
a significant percentage of people who,
perhaps you're new to them.
So can we walk through kind of what happened?
Yeah sure, yeah.
I mean-
Well as I could remember, yeah.
Well, we'll go,
we'll walk it up to the,
until you're in this induced coma but,
(both laugh)
I mean essentially as I understand it,
you were coming off an injury that you had sustained trying
to qualify for Olympic Trials,
where you put your foot in a pothole, right?
Was that at Boston, which marathon was?
Let me think, when was that, Houston.
Houston, that's right, Houston, right?
And you were like on paced or run 216 at the time
or something like that.
Yeah we were running on 216.
Tore your meniscus.
Yeah.
You're out, you're injured.
And, as you start to kind of,
repair yourself and wrap your head around,
perhaps beginning to train again,
you go out to the Grand Canyon.
So why don't we just pick it up there?
Yeah,
let's see.
That was probably in,
'cause Houston was in January and yeah it was 20-
Summer of 2020.
Yeah.
Well, the marathon was some months prior to that right?
Yeah, yeah,
yeah, January of 2020.
And then, so I was out for a few months.
I tore my meniscus and I also tore my,
the short head of my biceps femoris,
one of my hamstring,
(Tommy clears throat)
excuse me.
And that I think was what,
what really was holding me back.
And so that takes a long time,
to heal from that stuff.
And,
I was in a funk, I mean, it was a hard,
it was a really hard time and,
it's just as the pandemic was starting.
And, so this kind of collective sense of,
discontent, you know?
It was a strange time and
yeah, and I was just trying to,
trying to put my head back together.
I mean,
that was something that I'd been working for,
really the greater part of my entire,
my adult life.
And in my head it was like,
"Okay, this is probably the last chance
I have to get there."
I mean you know that you can't do it when you're 40,
but in my head, I was-
Right, 36 at the time.
36 yeah.
So I was running out of time.
It seemed and,
and you know my thought was like,
"Okay, I'll do this running the Olympic Trials.
That will be just kind of a lifelong goal that I've had.
And then after that,
I can now get serious about running in the mountains,
doing trails and ultras and stuff like that."
And,
so I was down in the canyon,
I'd been there a couple of times,
and it really is just a place to,
that place is, special.
And,
it was a,
it's always just been a chance to go down
and just kind of reconnect with myself
and with just that space.
And it's always been a place that rather
than going there to hurt,
it's been a place that I'd go to not hurt,
if that makes sense.
And,
so I wanted to see,
kind of just test my durability,
you know see how I was doing.
And so I went down there with a friend, Derek Lytle,
and he's a,
he's an accomplished,
ultra runner,
videographer, photographer.
And he's tough.
I mean he, I think a few years before that he was doing,
he was attempting the FKT Fastest Known Time
on the Arizona Trail,
you know from Utah, down there.
Self-supported, you know so he's carrying all of his stuff
and he got in a bad situation, got caught in rain,
like three days in a row.
And so I drove out and met him
and brought him a Subway sub, and a Coke,
and sat there and-
Yeah.
And he mopped for a little bit.
And then, I drove him in and helped him, DNF basically.
(both laugh)
And so,
and, you know I'd spent some time
doing some work with him before and,
he's, a good dude,
somebody that you wanna have,
have your back when you're in a bad situation, you know?
So, our plan was just to run across the canyon and back.
And, it was in June, which is really hot
down in the canyon.
So we were gonna go down, Bright Angel Trail,
across and then up, North Cave avenue.
Rim or ram.
Yeah, yeah.
The Inverted Mountain.
Yeah, exactly.
(Tommy chuckles)
Yeah,
and, you know it's so hot that time of year,
the only way to really do it is,
through the middle of the night.
So we left at sunset and started our way down.
And,
I had,
I kind of had a lingering headache for a couple of days.
And prior to that,
and I'd been in the canyon,
maybe three days before that.
Mhmh.
And I figured I just wasn't hydrated well enough
and that,
I didn't feel great about it,
but I thought,
"Well, this is fine, I've got a long time.
I can, focus on hydration and nutrition on the way down,
and, it'll be all right."
Well you left out the part about being in the canyon.
I don't know if it was the day before
or a couple of days before,
where you were down in there and you encountered a woman
at the base-
Yeah.
Who was having problems and you gave her all your food
and your hydration.
(Rich chuckles)
And then you had to get out of there without any of that,
not knowing that you're harboring this illness at the time.
Yeah, that was the weird thing,
is that I think that was a,
I think it was a Wednesday,
actually that I was down there by myself,
and I met a lady that was with some friends and she,
gosh, she was in a bad, bad situation.
And it's incredible, there,
because the pandemic was going
and there weren't,
there weren't rangers down there,
there weren't people down there.
And there's this sense of,
there's this false sense of security that we have.
I feel, you know in the US and a lot of situations,
that somebody will always bail you out.
You know that if something goes wrong,
well you've got insurance,
somebody will always make it right, you know?
And man, some of these places,
and dead is dead, you know?
And there's nobody,
nobody that's gonna come and bail you out.
There's not a meal train,
that's gonna pick you up and take you back.
And,
they were out of water,
and arguing with me about the GPS that,
Phantom Ranch was supposed to be a half mile away,
according to the GPS.
And I had just been there
and I was on my way back,
you know I had to tell her, "It's like,
well, it's actually like three miles."
And they argued with me like,
"Oh, it says on the GPS, it's a quarter mile"
(Rich laughs)
That sound like, "Look I've been here a million times."
Yeah, I promise you, it's three miles.
And, there's no water between here and there.
And it was, oh gosh,
I mean, down there at the bottom, it's like,
it's not an exaggeration that,
120 or 130 degrees in the summer.
Oh, I didn't realize that.
Just 'cause it,
it reflects off the rock walls and it's just,
it's just so hot.
And, she was shaky and her face was purple,
and I'm talking to her and trying to explain
how to get there.
And, she passed out,
like she lost consciousness
and I'm trying to hold her there,
trying to figure out where I can set her on these rocks
so that I can do CPR if I need to.
But the rocks are so jagged that it's like,
okay, if I can press on her chest,
I'm for sure gonna break her back because there's no,
everything is just so rugged right there.
Anyway, her friends come around the corner
and it takes a lot of persuading
for them to just finally believe me that it's actually,
a few more miles down the trail.
And,
anyway I got out of there and they were, I don't know,
actually, I don't know what ended up happening to 'em,
but,
so, I got pretty dehydrated on my way back out,
and figured that's what it was, you know?
So a couple of days later I'm in there
and I have this headache,
(Tommy clears throat)
and I'm thinking that's the same
that it's related to that.
Just overdoing it a few days before.
So we get down to the bottom of the canyon
we are at Phantom Ranch,
and we fill up and eating and drinking
and we continue on,
excuse me.
And we get to, this place called Cottonwood.
It's the next place to fill up the water bottles
and we keep going from there.
And then I,
I finally tell Derek,
I was like, "something doesn't feel right."
I can't cool down.
I could tell my heart rate was,
it was way too high,
for where we were.
I was like, "I don't know if I can,
if I can do this,
I don't know if this is a good idea to do this."
And, he was really cool about it.
He was like, "Yeah, that's smart."
And he
he's well enough,
has enough experience in that kind of thing to know that
if you don't have a great feeling about something,
you should probably listen to it in a situation like that,
but then you don't want to let your friend down, you know?
And,
so we flipped around and went back to Phantom Ranch and
was laying there and just staring up at the stars
and it was midnight or right around,
between between midnight
and one in the morning.
And, I couldn't get my heart rate down
and I couldn't my breathing under control
and I couldn't, I couldn't cool my body down.
And, then I finally cool down
and then I couldn't warm back up.
And that's never a good sign.
if you can't, regulate your body's temperature,
that's never good.
And I remember thinking that was it,
like,
that was where I was gonna die.
I was like,
"I'm going to die on a picnic table in Phantom Ranch,
because I didn't hydrate properly."
And I remember thinking that was-
You were chocking that all up to hydration.
I thought that's what it was, yeah.
Just 'cause everything,
you assess different things.
It's like, "Okay, if I've eaten enough,
have I drinken enough?
Are my electrolytes okay?"
And if it's not water or food or electrolytes or oxygen,
it's like, "What could it possibly be?"
And,
it's not that complicated typically, you know?
And we troubleshoot and try to figure out,
"Okay, where am I deficient?"
And just didn't make any sense.
And so reluctantly
we just start trudging our way back out.
And it took, usually it takes about two hours
to get back out.
And it took like 12, I think.
Wow.
And it was bad.
I mean, by the time I got up to the top,
my breathing was so shallow
I was really just wheezing and got back to his truck and I,
I just blacked out,
like as soon as he got back to the truck and,
he drove back to Flag and he was cool through all of it.
You know he was just like, "Oh, this thing happens,
you just overdid it."
And I know, he'd probably get in shit for it,
you know later it was like.
(Tommy chuckles)
Did you feel it?
Were you having respiratory, like distress though?
Were you like coughing up blood and stuff like that?
Literally, yeah.
But, that also is not that uncommon
if you start to cough a lot, it's like,
"Okay, am I,
is that blood coming from my lungs
or is that blood coming from,
just my throat?"
if you cough too much,
that can just happen sometimes.
And so there was a little bit of that.
And then in the days after, that I got home and,
I just assumed I had COVID.
I mean, all my-
Yeah.
All my symptoms just,
seemed like
it was still early on,
not a lot was known and
this dry non-productive cough,
and,
chills and night sweats and-
Of course its COVID.
Right.
I mean, we're in the middle of a pandemic,
you're having this respiratory thing.
I mean how could it not be COVID.
And it was irregular,
like it was unlike anything
that you'd kind of experienced before.
So, everybody would have assumed that.
Yeah, it was a different kind of cough,
and it really,
I mean, it was so bad that I coughed
and coughed and coughed and then,
and you're so irritated that,
then there's a lot of blood,
you know you're coughing up a lot of blood,
and then you aspirate that blood.
And, I remember in the evenings, when I would fall asleep,
it was more like I would lose consciousness
rather than like actually falling asleep,
I'd cough and cough and cough
until you start to see stars.
And you start to choke on that,
and,
and then just wake up
and there's blood all over your pillow.
And it's like, "Oh, dang, that, wasn't good."
And
it was a situation that was delicate too because,
I went in and tried to get tested a few times.
Well, I went in and got tested a couple of times
and it came back negative.
And I remember arguing with the lady, I was like,
"How is it negative?
Like how,
you did your test wrong."
Cause like-
And it's summer 2020
so there was a lot of,
I mean, these tests were not great.
Right.
And it also was as strange as it sounds,
political too, and physicians were afraid to treat,
certain ways because,
if you acknowledge something,
then you were taking a political stance and,
it just became messy.
Trying to in my head, trying to figure out,
"Okay, what's the best way that I can receive treatment.
And also, how can I not take up resources?
How can I not take a ball hospital bed,
that there's a shortage already."
specifically in Flagstaff, there was-
Yeah you were very resistant
about going to the hospital.
Yeah, yeah.
And, I thought it was because,
"Okay, if this is COVID,
well, then I can just treat this at home."
like that's what you're supposed to do
is self isolate and you have,
I mean, I remember there were, it's like,
okay, for the first five days and then the next five days,
and the next five days there was this graph that,
we kinda knew how, it was supposed to respond and,
you feel better and then you feel worse
and then feel better and then you're,
then you're good.
And strangely, this was following a really similar arc.
And,
anyway so I figured that if I had,
a nice home and I had a place where I could isolate
from my family,
I had food, I had water,
I had air conditioning,
I had everything I needed.
And then there are people,
hundreds of people on the Navajo Reds
and the Hopi Reds,
that don't have,
don't have running water,
don't have plumbing,
don't have climate control in their houses.
Don't have,
a separate apartment that they can,
sequester themselves.
It just,
it seems so unfair to go to the hospital and take up a bed.
And so I thought, and maybe there was some hubris in this,
but I thought I,
I studied,
I've dabbled in the healthcare profession,
for quite a few years.
I feel like I understand how to triage.
Yeah, well you have a doctorate in physical therapy.
You're also one of the fittest people on the planet,
like you're just an absolute beast, like a specimen.
If anybody's gonna have the constitution to
kind of get through this, you would be that guy.
So on some level, it makes sense.
You're also not one to,
you're always thinking about everyone else.
So like your mind immediately goes to the Navajo Nation
when you're in a desperate need of attention yourself.
But, the smart piece of this is in retrospect, looking back,
if it turns out you don't have COVID
and then you go to the ER
and you're surrounded by people with COVID,
in a very compromised situation.
I mean, that could be cataclysmic.
Right, and that was the thinking.
It was like, "Okay, if this isn't COVID."
It had turned into,
again, this is self-diagnosis, but it felt like
it felt like bacterial pneumonia at that point.
And based of the stuff I was coughing up
and the symptoms.
And so,
my thought process was,
"Well, I just need the medication,
to be able to get through this
and I need an antibiotic, I need,
some specific,
medication to be able to,
to treat it.
And if this isn't COVID
and if I go to the hospital, I will 100% get COVID.
And if I get COVID, with bacterial pneumonia,
the prognosis is not great
for something like that."
And so, I was really stubborn,
and luckily Steph was more stubborn.
(Tommy chuckles)
And she was able to,
I guess speak some sense into me-
Well, she discovered you lying on the floor,
passed out in a full blood is what happened, right?
And it's like, enough is enough,
you're going to the hospital.
Yeah.
I think the way that she did it finally
was that she came home and put a,
pulse ox, like a pulse oximeter on my finger
and showed me my,
my oxygen saturation.
And it was bad.
I think maybe 72, which is not good.
And so, I was like, "Okay."
Really reluctantly, Steph tried arguing with me about it.
In my defense, typically,
when your CO2 is that high and your oxygen is that low,
it causes you to become really delirious
and really belligerent, actually-
It does.
And, so looking back,
I'd like to think that some of that stubbornness was,
(both laugh)
was just because I was I-
Induced by-
Unaltered state of consciousness, right.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome
but I want to snack a moment
to talk to you about importance of nutrition.
The thing is, most people I know actually
already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes,
into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet,
transformed my life so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience,
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the PlantPower Meal Planner,
are affordable, all-in-one digital platform,
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code, RRHEALTH, at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff people for just a dollar,
70 a week, literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH,
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
So you get into the hospital,
but then the next ordeal is trying to figure out,
"What the heck is going on here."
Yeah.
Like they couldn't diagnose this
for quite a long period of time.
I mean, it went from maybe it is COVID,
maybe it's a fungal infection.
Maybe it's pneumonia.
Maybe it's the bubonic plague,
like that was considered, right?
Yeah.
At some point,
and you're a guy who's traveled all over the world.
Like you've been in all these crazy places.
Like it's not farfetched that you could have contracted
some kind of parasite or something along the way.
Sure, yeah.
That was,
we had some really lengthy,
I remember having lengthy conversations
with the infectious disease specialist and,
he'd asked me these questions
and he was really adamant about it being the plague though
and that makes sense.
I mean,
that happens sometimes,
in Northern Arizona,
the rock chucks and the Prairie dogs can get it,
in their lungs.
Or you got it from rodents.
Yeah, exactly.
And it has to be,
it's similar to how COVID is red is that the,
the particles from,
from their chest or respiratory particles, essentially,
if you breathe them in, then you can contract it.
And so the questioning was like,
"Okay, have you, in the last month,
have you had contact,
(Tommy chuckles)
have you had contact with a Prairie dog
or a rock chuck?"
"I don't think so."
And then I remember thinking, I was like,
"Oh no, I did chase one in the Grand Canyon.
I followed it just looking at it
and watched it go into its hole."
And I remember looking into the hole."
And I remember thinking, I was like, it clicked,
I was like, "Oh, that's it."
Mhmh, all right.
Couldn't a dead rodent,
get into the water supply where you're refilling
your bottles down in the canyon."
Maybe,
I think that's pretty,
it's pretty,
well, I like to think that it's pretty clean down there,
that it's filtered pretty well, but,
I guess that was a possibility,
the way that he explained it as it had to be breathed in,
you know?
And so I remember thinking, "Oh, that was it,
that was the rock chuck that I saw."
And that was the one that did it to me.
And I told him, I was like, "Yeah, I did.
I saw one, actually took a picture of it."
You know?
And, then he asked, "Okay well, if it wasn't that,
did you potentially step on a rock chuck or a Prairie dog?"
I was like, "I'm pretty sure I didn't."
He said, "Well did anybody that you've run with
in the last month, potentially step on a rock chuck
or a Prairie dog, and you breathed in, whatever was,
squeezed out of its lungs."
I was like, "I don't think so."
And he said, "You need to, find out."
And so I was like, "Gosh, this is like,
contact tracing to the next level."
Contact anybody that may have may have,
stepped on a Prairie dog.
In the middle of the night, in the Grand Canyon,
when you can't see anything.
I mean, anything's possible.
Yeah.
So we eventually ruled that out
and it wasn't the plague.
And, then I remember they started talking about,
a couple of other different diagnoses,
and lymphoma was one that they brought up and I,
I really just kind of laughed at that.
I was like, "That's, like how, why,
how would I have lymphoma?"
And then I just assumed it was just,
I still thought it was COVID or something
that had to be related to COVID that just,
maybe wasn't detectable at the time.
And, that the testing just hadn't gotten,
that sensitive enough.
And, then I,
I think they,
I got to a point I think,
started to get really worried at that point.
It got to a point where they said they were gonna
need to put me on a ventilator
because I couldn't keep my oxygen level high enough.
And,
and I remember just,
talking to, Steph
and,
(Tommy clears throat)
leaving messages for the girls, you know that I
had to go to sleep for a couple of days.
And, that I'd be back soon,
and,
and, you know just,
not amused by all of it, but just really curious,
just kind of like,
"I wonder what, actually is going on,
and it will be interesting when I wake up,
to find out what actually had happened."
You know and-
Did, the prospect of going on the ventilator,
scare you a little bit,
because I just remember, that was the period of time when,
if you did have COVID and you're still thinking
you might have COVID you go on that ventilator,
a lot of people aren't coming off that ventilator.
Right, yeah.
And, I think I,
(Tommy sighs)
I don't think I,
knew enough about it, to be that freaked out,
because in my head,
I was like, "I'm not gonna die of COVID."
Like I,
it's people with pre-existing conditions that die of this,
it's people that have, or are at an advanced age,
and have comorbidities.
And, I remember being very aware that it was serious.
And, any time you have something
that's going on with your respiratory system,
you really quickly lose your ego.
I mean, you,
there's not much bartering,
then you can't, really tough your way through that.
you take away somebody's oxygen
and it's just,
(Tommy chuckles)
a matter of minutes and,
you're begging for somebody,
something, anything to save you.
I mean, that's why, it's like being waterboarded, you know?
And, there's a reason why, gosh, that's so effective.
Because there's this,
there's this fear that comes over you when,
everything protective within your body is telling you,
"You're gonna die,
like, you've got seconds."
You know?
Unless you change something and,
you know you become desperate,
and whatever it is
whatever it is, that needs to be done,
to be able to make you stop feeling-
Yeah.
You're willing to, do it,
you're willing to concede.
And,
yeah.
And yeah, that was kinda,
it's kind of where things started to just go,
blurry for me, 'cause,
after that, it was,
that was in July.
I think it was probably,
November before I-
Like your next memory.
Yeah, before I finally-
Where are you in and out of consciousness or you were,
you just don't have-
Well that's-
Recollection of that?
I do.
That's where things get really, really,
difficult to decipher.
I,
what it feels like is, I mean,
I've been told now,
that it's amnesia, retrograde amnesia and,
not having enough oxygen for so many,
weeks and months that there's,
irreparable brain damage and things like that.
And,
(Tommy clears throat)
what it felt like was that, all of these files that I had
over the last, gosh, maybe 10 years,
were corrupted.
And,
and then,
during those months that I was,
in a coma,
I,
I wasn't here, but I was still,
(Tommy sighs)
I was somewhere and what I experienced was,
you know time is interesting.
Time can distort time, can fold back on itself,
time can be stretched.
And I experienced lifetimes.
And during those weeks and months,
and then the really tricky thing is that,
then when I started to have the realization
that I was back here, wherever here is,
all of those experiences
that I had when I was asleep, I guess.
Steph and I call it, when I was in the in-between,
wherever it was.
It's as though they got planted back in,
where all of those corrupted files had been
and just kinda mixed together.
So that the interesting thing is that, they didn't,
they didn't get filed as though they were dreams.
They got filed as though they were memories.
And,
and so everything from the last decade,
has been mixed with all of these other experiences and-
So you still have trouble sort of parsing those things
and making sense of what was real
and what transpired in the liminal space.
Yeah exactly.
So what was that experience,
what, like, where do you think you went,
like paint that picture for me of being in that in-between.
Oh gosh.
(Tommy chuckles)
That's hard.
There,
there was,
exhaustion, I think,
is the overwhelming feeling that I felt initially.
And it was,
that I was trying so hard to stay here.
I could sense that something was pulling me,
and it was painful, it was uncomfortable.
I was trying really, really hard,
to not leave whatever this was,
whether we think of it as a, like a cage
trying to stay within that cage.
And, I'm trying to be held by my body still.
And, then I remember,
there was a time where I,
I was just so tired,
just so, so tired.
And I remember thinking,
"I don't want to do this anymore.
I don't think I can do this anymore."
And, by then, I I'd lost any recollection
that I,
that I had a life here.
I didn't remember that I had kids.
I didn't remember, that I lived in Flagstaff,
that I,
any of it.
And there was a,
there was a point where the weird thing is that,
Steph was always with me the entire time.
I thought, we were on this just grand adventure, you know?
That we were exploring the cosmos together.
And, I got to a point where,
it's gonna be hard.
(Tommy sighs)
I stopped,
I made the conscious decision that I was gonna be done,
that I didn't wanna fight,
whatever was pulling me away anymore,
that I didn't have the strength to fight it anymore.
And, there was a sense of,
(Tommy sighs)
peace and just,
comfort in wherever it was that I was going.
And,
I saw it,
and it was inviting
and beautiful,
and safe.
And,
and Steph nudged me and she said,
"You've got to go back."
And I said, "I don't, wanna go back,
like, look at this place."
I said, "Come with me,
just come with me, like, don't you want to be here too?"
And she,
(Tommy chuckles)
she grabbed my face,
and turned my head.
And,
I said, "I don't want to go back."
And she said,
she said, "You don't, have a choice."
And she pointed,
and I could see in the distance,
my girls ,
and I had forgotten,
that they even existed.
And,
she said, "You don't have a choice,
you've got those three little girls
that you've got to go home to."
And,
(Tommy sighs)
I remember seeing it and,
and being so angry,
just,
because I felt like, "I don't know how I'm gonna do this.
I don't have the strength to go back,
I'm so done, I'm so ready to,
just stop fighting, whatever this is."
And,
(Tommy sighs)
I remember just closing my eyes and breathing and just,
kind of just accepting it.
It was like, "Okay
I guess I don't have a choice.
I guess I have to come back."
And then the,
the pull, all of that fighting that I had done,
to stay where I had been initially,
it was the same amount of effort to come back to that space.
And I remember when I finally did come back
and I got here, wherever that is,
(Tommy chuckles)
I was so angry, I was angry at my physicians,
I was angry at Steph,
I was angry at everybody that had prayed me back, you know?
Because it felt as though,
I couldn't even choose to die the way I wanted, you know?
Because the pull of,
(Tommy chuckles)
that pull was so strong, you know?
Whatever it was,
that pulled me back when I had chosen to,
I hadn't chosen where I just didn't know
how I could continue doing it.
I just felt like I didn't have the strength to continue,
the ability to continue that amount of discomfort
and that amount of effort.
And,
(Tommy sighs)
and I got back,
and woke up, I guess,
it's not that simple, but,
and I was in this shell of a body
and I was like, "What did you,
what'd you guys do to my lungs?
What'd you do to my body?
What'd you do to,
you know I weighed 95 pounds and-
How long,
do you know how long you had been,
under at that point?
This was coming out of the coma?
Yeah.
So this was like, how many weeks or months?
It was, gosh, I don't even know.
It was, Steph said that there were times that,
in August and September, you know that I,
that I was responsive to certain things.
It was way later than that before I actually
was able to piece together what was going on
before I understood,
excuse me,
before I understood that I was in the ICU,
that I had lymphoma, that I was undergoing chemo,
all of those things,
that was probably November before I actually realized that.
But, you know I woke up with had pressure ulcers on my heels
and on my shoulder and on my sacrum,
my I've got a scar, you know the size of my fist,
on my tailbone,
where, you know just from having to be in the same position.
Bedsores.
Yeah the bedsores,
you know they just happen if you can't be shifted and-
But this idea,
like the mysteries of consciousness,
when you're in a comatose state, right?
Is fascinating and you have this,
you know basically, near death experience
that you recollect with incredible clarity.
Yeah.
The idea that you had awareness,
in that liminal space is fascinating.
And coming out of that,
and now with some time and distance between that experience
and, where you're at now,
like, what do you, you make of that,
like spiritually, you know?
Like that's a trip
Right, yeah.
I talked to Steph like, initially,
right as it was happening
and,
(Tommy chuckles)
there was,
at the time, it was very clear,
and there were more answers than questions.
But as I look back now,
there's now more questions than answers.
And what I did say to Steph,
(Tommy chuckles)
and I remember thinking was that,
and of course,
this was my experience.
And I don't know how,
who knows how much of it is.
I don't see it in any way as though like,
"Oh, I discovered the truth."
I had this vision, I had this experience,
and this is the experience that you have.
I don't, feel that way at all.
It was the experience that I had,
but,
I remember,
(Tommy chuckles)
we continue.
It's not just darkness, it doesn't just end.
And it's right here, it's all happening right here,
but it's different.
I remember realizing that, okay,
if I become unmoored from this body,
I can't go back, and I will still be here, right here.
All of this will still be happening,
but I won't have the ability to communicate
with everybody who's still in that space.
And I remember thinking how agonizing that would be
to see my girls and that they would still be right here,
but I wouldn't be able to communicate to them.
I wouldn't be able to let-
But you would have awareness of the other dimension.
But also complete awareness of all of their fear
and all of their questions and all of their grief
and all of their heartache and being able to see it
and feel all of it,
but not be able to reach across and say,
but I'm still right here, just so
I'm still right here.
Wow.
The fear of that was a huge motivator.
I remember also thinking and feeling and seeing
that heaven and hell and they exist,
but they exist to everybody simultaneously.
And they exist in proportion to the amount of love
that we give and the amount of love
that we're able to receive.
And then the hell part is the recollection
and the understanding of all of the love that we didn't give
and didn't receive when we could have,
and that heaven and hell exists simultaneously
based off of the different relationships that we had
while we had the opportunity to express those things.
That there could be a sense of heaven.
It's such a big term, but a sense of peace
with the way that we conducted ourselves
with a certain individual and the complete opposite
was an awareness of the way
that we connect to ourselves with somebody else.
And that it's all connected, that it all continues.
And that, gosh, just the urgency of now
and that what we continue to feel beyond this
is directly linked with the way
that we interact with people.
Comfort ourselves now.
Exactly, yeah.
And that's so powerful.
That's such a powerful lesson.
It's also like encouraging to me,
it makes me feel good and safe, in some regard.
It gives me a sense of agency and kind of a directive
about how to live.
But it's comforting to hear that.
And I suspect you being where you're at right now,
which is obviously in a better place than you were,
but also somewhat precarious, there's some comfort for you
in having that awareness and understanding.
Yeah, there is in some sense,
but the part of the fear that I had as I experienced that
was that I remember feeling as though
whatever it is beyond here, beyond this,
it's not bad, it's not scary, but it's not here.
And it's lovely, whatever it is when it happens,
but I'm not ready yet.
I don't want to go yet.
Because I like it here, you know?
This is the after party, there's no after-party,
this is as good as it gets.
This is everything right now.
And whatever is beyond this, it doesn't necessarily,
it's not necessarily bad, but my girls aren't there.
My family's not there.
My friends aren't there.
My life is not there, it's here.
And gosh, I want to stay here as long as I can.
And just wring everything out of this experience first.
How does that color, how you kind of navigate
your life day to day now?
Has it changed?
Obviously you're more self-aware of your mortality.
I suspect you're more present with each given moment
and understanding the preciousness of,
I mean, you have young girls, it's like, it's the best.
But to be able to have that awareness and enjoy it
while it's happening, rather than in retrospect,
it's certainly a gift.
I mean that right there, like you nailed it.
That's been the biggest takeaway
is that there is not this idealistic future,
somewhere down the line where we're going to find happiness,
where happiness exists there and we're going to be happy.
That we're going to get there
and everything's going to be right
and we're going to have this sense of just contentment
and rest and ease.
It's like that doesn't exist.
It's right now, it's all happening this very moment.
It's the choice, you think about how to experience
your life moment to moment.
The heaven and hell,
heaven and hell are all happening all the time to all of us.
The entire range of human emotions, experiences,
all of that is happening to us all the time.
And whether or not we experienced that joy, that happiness
is based on our ability to see it as it's happening
rather than in retrospect,
rather than looking back and saying, oh, oh, okay,
I was happy, I didn't realize it but I was,
things were really good back then.
Those were the good old days.
We don't ever realize that until after the fact
and our ability to have joy, to have happiness, to be happy.
It's 100% based on our capacity
to see it as it's happening.
I mean this right here, there's nothing.
I remember thinking that this morning,
it was cold this morning, it was windy this morning.
There's construction going on.
It's loud, there's a bunch of cars driving away too fast,
but it was also, the sun was out.
I could hear the ocean.
I can breathe without carrying oxygen with me.
I can eat through my mouth.
I don't have a tube anymore in my stomach.
I can take a shower by myself.
I don't have to bring oxygen into there.
My heart rate doesn't go to 190
just because the hot water hits my body.
I can use the toilet by myself.
I don't have to wear a diaper.
I don't have bedsores right now.
I don't have to piss out of a catheter.
All of those things.
The absence of all of those things is remarkable.
I mean, it's incredible, it's a miracle.
And the ability to see that right now,
this situation, that there's nothing
that could make it any better.
I mean, I have contact with my family.
I saw them just a couple of days ago,
I'll see them tomorrow.
I have my girls, I have a house, I have a car,
we have climate control.
We have all of this stuff,
there's nothing that can make it any better, nothing.
I mean, really, I sincerely believe that here's nothing
that could improve this situation.
But here's the thing,
I feel like you're somebody who already understood that,
like you've conducted your life in accordance
with those values all along.
I suspect maybe you're in a graduate degree program
with that, but it's not like you were living your life
antithetically to those principles prior to your illness.
Like you seem like a guy who understood that before.
Maybe, I mean maybe in theory,
but I don't know, I'm cynical.
I'm grumpy, a lot of what comes out,
whether I say it or whether I write it
or however it's expressed is the conversation
that I'm having with myself, trying to help myself realign,
trying to help myself focus on what's good,
facing a challenge,
being honest about what that challenge consists of,
figuring out what I can control and focusing on that
and then spinning a positive narrative around it.
Excuse me.
But gosh, it's always been the conversation
that's going on in my head, that inner dialogue I guess,
to try to face whatever it is that I'm going through,
I guess, in an optimistic sense.
But that doesn't mean it's ever been easy,
gosh, I don't know.
In this whole situation,
the things that have been the most challenging
are things that you wouldn't necessarily think about.
I wouldn't have thought about.
Like what?
Waking up addicted to pain, gosh, that's been.
What did they have you on?
It's like a battery of opiods, morphine.
Yeah, fentanyl morphine and that stuff is lovely.
I don't think I've ever grieved the loss of something
as much as that.
Yeah, it becomes everything, that's how you get through,
that's how you get through those insurances.
It's like how do people endure that?
It's like, well you endure it
because you have a drink of morphine, right?
That stuffs 50 times more potent than heroin,
and coming off of that, that in combination with,
you're on everything and you're on it
because you need to be on it.
I mean, I don't know how you could endure
what you go through, if you weren't heavily medicated.
But then when the time comes to, a lot of the times,
it seems as though you're medicated
because they don't actually think
you're going to make it through.
So it's like, okay, make this as comfortable as possible.
This is pain management, yeah.
Yeah as you transition out and then,
well then you don't die.
And then it's like, oh, damn okay.
We've got to figure out how to get your body
to where it can function without all of this.
And that was hard.
That's still hard.
I mean to say that I don't think the pull ever goes away
and you just have to jump it, from that to something else.
It'll slowly, slowly fade into the background, but yeah,
it never quite goes away.
It's always lurking in the background, man.
Well, it's been something that it's not new to me.
I think addiction is so ubiquitous
that I have a hard time even referring
to people's as addicts.
'Cause I think that people are humans
and that we're driven by these gods and their dopamine
and serotonin and oxytocin.
And there's lots of different things that we do
to be able to have the right combination of those.
And some of them are culturally and socially acceptable
and some of them aren't
and some are more potentially self-destructive than others.
We all on some level find our way to the drug
that works for us.
And that could be shopping or television,
or it can be a morphine drip, whatever it is,
and every combination in between.
But I think we all gravitate to that thing
that kind of solves that problem in our brain
that we feel like we're missing.
Yeah, and the interesting thing, like for me,
as I've gone into, I guess just most recently with this,
just experiencing it, to me it felt as though
as a misconception, when we look at people
and think why would so-and-so,
they have a beautiful family, they have a great job.
They have a nice house, they have a beautiful life.
Like why would they choose to use something like that
when they know how self or how destructive it can be
as though there's something malicious in it.
Right, that shit has nothing to do with it.
Exactly.
And my view of that, I guess, most recently with this
the reason that somebody goes to use something like that
is because they love their life
because they love their family because they love
the version of themselves when they're on that.
And they hate the version of themselves
when they're not on it,
because their friends actually don't like
the version of them when they're not on it,
because society doesn't respond well to that version,
that it actually in some situations,
when you're completely dependent upon it,
it does make you a better person.
It does make you more capable of functioning
within whatever that life that you've created is.
And gosh, people think about how expensive
those types of things are,
and how inconvenient those things are.
But it's like, gosh, rehab and sobriety
and coming off of those things, gosh, that's expensive
and there's never a convenient time for that.
It will absolutely,
just rock everything that you have going on.
I mean, I spent three weeks in a bed just whiling.
Just trying to detox.
And just shaking and it felt like my brain,
my spinal cord, my entire nervous system
was having an allergic reaction.
It's like if your brain could itch,
and just such a strong pull that you know that in it,
all you have to take is one of these little beautiful
little white pills.
And within 10 minutes it's gone
and you can stop that.
And you will go to the ends of the earth
to solve that equation.
Yeah.
So heavy, man.
Yeah, but it's good though,
it's good to experience that and to just to realize
there's just such this misconception
that we have that there's malicious intent.
That if somebody struggles with something like that,
it's because they're deviant, they're malevolent,
it's because they just-
They're on a search for wholeness
and that comes in various forms.
But when you find that drug and you latch onto it,
it's really hard to let go.
And you being somebody
who's already innately very compassionate and empathetic
towards other human beings
it just deepens that reservoir of empathy.
And helps suspend judgment for those that struggle
and are in pain and in that vicious cycle.
There you go.
Yeah, it's hard.
Well, we glossed over like the diagnosis.
I mean you have this rare lymphoma,
but the actual diagnosis is primary pulmonary NKT cell,
right?
And this is like a crazy rare thing.
Like it's surprising that they were able to diagnose you
because so few people, how many cases are there?
There's almost no cases.
Yeah, I don't know.
Yeah, stay out of that part of that.
That's the part that's a little bit tricky,
I start to hear or I start to read about it or research
or I hear kinda overhear stuff
and it doesn't bolster my confidence.
So I stay away from it.
So in the hospital five months?
Oh boy.
Don't even know.
July through January,
January, February, March, right, July, August, September,
October, seven months, yeah seven months or so.
Steph wrote, she kind of went through the litany
of all the procedures that you endured.
Are you aware of these?
'Cause I was thinking about recounting some of them,
but if you don't want to be.
Yeah on a surface level.
You're aware, you know what they did you.
Yeah, I think so.
When they plucked and brought it out of you.
I mean, basically we don't have to find a point on this,
but multiple surgeries, most of them while sedated,
ventilator intubation, which we mentioned,
open lung biopsy, ECMO placement in both your jugular
and femoral vein, tracheotomy, PEG GI feeding,
two chest tubes for collapsed lungs and internal bleeds.
You suffered acute liver failure.
You had deep vein thrombosis in your arm.
You had a stage three sacral pressure ulcer
and two different strains of fungal lung infections,
as well as a septic blood infection.
You suffered from severe ICU and steroid induced delirium.
Many days you were unable to recognize stuff
or even remember your own name.
You lost 70 pounds of muscle going from 170
down to 98, 95 pounds, something like that.
You had to relearn how to talk, how to swallow,
how to chew, you strain but succeeded to speak
on a Passy-Muir valve, which I don't know what that is
while still on ECMO and a ventilator.
You had to relearn how to move your limbs
beginning with your finger and your toes.
This took weeks.
This is insane, it goes on and on and on.
Do you have memory of these phases and stuff like that?
Yeah, the surgeries, all the procedures,
I've got big scars now.
And I've learned about a lot of this just from
a lot of it happened when I was, I guess in a coma.
And so I woke up with all these incisions
or just with tubes still connected.
And some of it, the crazy part is that
some of these procedures I was sedated for,
but I remember them as they were happening.
And I remember, I've got this scar here.
Right, wow, right on your sternum.
Yeah, right on my sternum and I forget this is audio.
It's video too.
Yeah, a big scar right where my sternum was.
And that was a pericardial window.
I guess there was a way to go in and access my heart
for some different procedures I had.
And then to do some work on, it's called your pericardium,
which is this.
They had to drain fluid to drain the fluid
out of that sack, right?
Yeah to drain fluid out of that and then that basically
was just kept open so that they could go
and keep working there.
And then eventually you can't stitch it
because there's just too big of a hole.
And so that was cauterized.
And I, excuse me, I remember that, I remember smelling.
They have to do a skin graft on that
or how did they even get it to cover up?
Just burn, just cauterize, and I remember smelling it
and it reminded me of like branding cattle
when I was younger.
And I was like, why does it smell
like we're branding cattle?
And then I realized that the smell was coming from me,
from my chest and feeling it.
And I remember thinking, guys, I can feel this,
this thing that you're doing, I'm still here,
but not being able to communicate like, okay,
can you give me something?
Or can you put me out 'cause I may not be responsive,
but I'm still here and I was uncomfortable.
And then that's the other thing that where everything
is just so confusing, that I was still experiencing
lots of stuff.
Some of it was just horrible,
and just the most uncomfortable things you can imagine.
And I've heard people say like that these things
that you go through when you're in the ICU,
end of life, stuff like that,
that there are these dehumanizing experiences,
having a catheter, a rectal catheter,
being fed through a tube, having a tube down your throat,
a tube in your throat, through your nose, through your neck,
all of these things.
And it's interesting that there's nothing more humanizing.
Those are humanizing, the very most humanizing experiences.
Because it connects you with just the frailty
of being human or the temporal nature
of our short existence here on earth.
And everybody will be well, hopefully not,
but if we live to an advanced stage
and if we don't go out with a bang,
if we go out with a whimper instead,
it looks like that and everybody will be in that situation.
And realizing that maybe somebody says something
and it comes across really gruff.
And it's not because they don't mean to say it
in that kind of way.
It's because they know they've only got enough energy
for three or four words,
and they're only going to have the energy
to get it out one time.
And I remember working with patients,
geriatric patients and I remember thinking
wow that's really interesting how curt you become
as you get older.
Just self preservation, yeah.
Right, exactly.
You don't have the luxury of considering
how something is going to come out
or how it's going to be interpreted
because you only have the energy
to just say something one time.
Just being able to be aware of that and see that
and experience it.
Yeah, the kind of silver lining in this
is you had that palliative care experience
without being a geriatric and you have this second shot
to basically ply what you learned and attempt
to make your life more meaningful in the process.
The people who work in palliative care, it's fascinating.
They're getting a firsthand experience with people
at the end of their lives and their last words
and their reflections on their lives.
And I find that to be so powerful and instructive,
and yet you hear it and then you forget it immediately
and you just go about your business.
For me and the one thing I got to say though,
is, oh man, nurses and the doctors, the physicians,
I think about this situation and I guess
some of the feedback I've gotten
and some of the messages I've received and stuff,
this is not a story of heroic feats.
I mean, at least not by me.
And when I think about it, it's like the nurses
and the physicians that chose to take me,
when everything looked so bleak,
really putting their reputations on the line
to be able to do this and to be able to be willing
to take me when there was such a limit,
like limited resources, limited bed space, limited manpower,
all of that.
It's difficult to find the right words
to express that kind of gratitude.
And not just to the team that accepted me
and was willing to work with me,
but also with just the outpouring of support,
and love from, gosh, from so many people.
I don't know what your awareness is
because you were where you were,
but the outpouring of love and the support online
and the community that kind of congealed
around supporting you was unbelievable, man.
It was really a beautiful thing.
And I'm sure you know that,
but if you don't know that you need to know that,
people love you, man.
And that's a reflection of the way
that you've lived your life, to the extent that,
your experience has created a referendum
on how you want to live and how you want to be
and improvements you can make,
you need to understand that you have lived your life
in such a way that people are going to the ends of the earth
to try to find ways to support you and your family.
Yeah people are good.
All we here is the negative.
All we see is the scandals, the times that people mess up
and just this obsession we have with finding fault
and that it fosters this mindset
as though humans are just these fallible wretched,
cynical creatures.
And that's one aspect of humanity,
but our ability to do good,
to impact the lives of people around us
to help make things better for other people around us.
It's infinite, that capacity, that ability
I think about humanity.
And we talk about humanity all the time.
Well, we did, growing up at least in my home.
My mom was an artist and my dad,
his graduate degrees were in humanities and religion.
That's fascinating.
I didn't know that, but I'm like, of course.
But growing up, we studied the masters of the humanities.
They were the artists, they were the writers,
and that word became synonymous
with like masters of the arts.
They were great writers or painters or sculptors.
When we think about Michael Angelo or Bernini,
or we think about these individuals that have this ability
to capture human emotion, human experience.
And that's why we call it the humanities.
It's not synonymous with artists,
it's that they have the ability to capture
the essence of humanity.
Not just have the ability to paint
or to be a sculptor but to actually capture a feeling,
this universal human experience.
And there's this massive,
I think about this massive spectrum of humanity.
And in one end is the weak, miserable,
wretched aspects of humanity.
But then on the other essence or on the other side
of that spectrum is our potential for good,
and we are masters at picking up the broken pieces
and recreating and repairing
and we're masters of redemption.
We really are, and we're also masters at deflecting
the fact that we have that capacity,
we put it on something else or someone else always,
we look at these incredible achievements
that humans have accomplished.
And our first reaction is, oh, it must be extraterrestrials.
It must be something.
Right, we couldn't have possibly achieved this.
Exactly, because if we recognize our capacity
as human beings then we also,
well, if we recognize the achievements
of a previous civilization or somebody else,
and if we don't attribute it to divine intervention
or some unseen force that actually accomplished it,
then it condemns us as human beings.
Then we have to acknowledge the fact that,
well we maybe aren't reaching our potential
as human beings.
And so we're so quick to give something else
the credit, which is great.
It's important to have humility.
Right, but to face that is to reckon
with our innate power.
And if we're living our life frivolously,
we don't want to look at that.
Exactly, yeah.
But when we realize our life is ours to choose essentially,
I mean if there's something that we want to accomplish,
there's work involved, there's personal responsibility
that we have to take and we have to actually do that.
But it is within our capacity
and it is within our ability
and gosh to be able to see that potential
that we have as human beings.
And to realize that that redemptive capacity
that exists within each of us is a human characteristic,
to realize that not just the flawed broken aspects
of our humanity, but our potential.
And what we can do individually,
but also what we can do collectively.
And seeing that play out with this experience,
that the support that my family continues to receive
from so many, I can't even begin to number them
just because it's just immeasurable and the contributions,
the generosity, the support, the encouragement,
all of that, seeing that and just realizing,
remembering as I see that, just that incredible capacity
that we have for good.
Yeah, it reaffirms my optimism about humanity,
amidst all the chaos and the strife and the division
and this breakdown in our ability to communicate
and the lack of nuance in our discourse
and our quick to judge kind of disposition
and canceling people for this and that,
like this idea of redemption right?
Is so important and this appreciation of nuance
and this default to trying to find, or trying to identify
the best in people or see the potential
in our individual and collective humanity
is something that I feel like we need to reconnect with
and appreciate.
I feel like it's evaporating, right before our very eyes
and we're all suffering as a result.
That's what makes us human, it is the fact that all of us
have these secret boxes that are full of our fears,
our grief, our insecurities, as well as our hopes
and dreams and aspirations.
Sure, and then sort of sitting right next to that
is a culture that's biding its time,
just waiting to judge you in accordance with your worst day.
Right, yeah, exactly.
I love this idea of artists as doctors of humanity, right?
Here to kind of help us connect with what we all share.
And I feel like you channel that sensibility
in your writing,
like when you make these beautiful Instagram posts,
they're really, they're poems,
they're musings philosophical on the human condition.
They're not about you.
They're not even really about running.
They're really about life.
And they're very broad and sometimes they're very specific,
but they always speak to something
that we can all connect with and share
about what it is to be in this meat suit
and deal with the that we have to deal with as human beings.
Yeah.
They're beautiful.
I love reading your writing and Steph too.
Like the two of you together,
it's like, just write a book together.
That's incredible.
Thank you, that means a lot.
It's always just been my journal, really,
and from the time I was a kid
we were encouraged to write every day.
And my dad has had a journal that he writes in
and has kept since the 1970s.
And it's like 17,000 pages long.
Wow.
He writes it every month and then prints it out
and sends it to each of us and it's basically that,
it's just his thoughts and the things that he reads
and the things that he experiences.
And so we were always taught to do that,
that, that was something that you should do on a daily basis
is to sit down and write.
And my little daughter, my oldest of the three,
she's old enough to where she can do something like that.
She can sit down and write,
and that's something that their allowance is based of.
It's like, if you write every day,
at the end of the month, you can add all this up.
Oh, its cool.
And just because it's a way to express,
to identify what it is that you're feeling,
and to be able to put it down on paper.
And it validates that experience for you.
And if there's other people
that it can be helpful to them as well, then it's excuse me.
And you can do it in a way that's generic enough to where.
Yeah.
And that's what that's always been.
Even before social media,
that's always just been something that I've done
and it's something I still do.
I mean, I don't share a lot of it,
but getting in the practice of writing,
I think that there's this quote by Hemingway,
where he talks about writing one true thing.
He sits down and he just write one true sentence,
write the truest sentence that.
And that's what it is a lot of days.
And it's not always this yearning
where I have to sit down and write something,
otherwise I'm not gonna be able to contain my thoughts.
It's a practice.
I sit down and I make myself write one true thing.
And sometimes I share that and sometimes I don't,
most of the times I don't.
But it's really helped me in the last several months,
as I've been trying to get.
There are aspects of my memory
that I don't think I'll ever get back,
but I feel like I'm finally being able to get my mind back,
have the ability to think and be able to,
I guess, process kinda just what's going on around me
and internalize that, and then be able to metabolize it
through putting it down on paper.
Yeah, it has a very beat poet vibe to it, right?
And it's cool 'cause I think,
we think of athletes being here
and then artists being over here.
Yeah.
And it's rare
when these two things come in one package.
And you see it kind of probably more in the ultra space,
because that's sort of a more kind of esoteric pursuit,
and I think is prone to kind of waxing poetic, I suppose.
But I love it when athletes are kind of channeling
that innate artistic sensibility that I think we all have.
When I think of you, I mean,
I think about Ricky Gates being somebody like that.
I don't know if you guys know each other.
You don't, sure, right?
I mean, you guys have a Vulcan mind meld, yeah.
No, he's really inspiring.
Yeah, and it's like notes from the edge.
We're out here, we're explorers of a certain kind,
and we're reporting back with what we discover out there,
and I think it's really cool.
The other piece to this is this default
to being service-minded, and I was reading or listening
to something your brother, Jacob, said.
And he was talking about when you guys
were in college and in Hawaii.
And really immersing yourself
in the indigenous Hawaiian culture
and trying to understand the precepts and principles
that kinda underpin their philosophy.
The idea of Ohana and Aloha and Mana and all of that,
but a core principle being this idea of ha,
this predisposition towards giving,
and the idea that when you are in a giving spirit,
that it is there that you find your greatest power.
Yeah.
So talk about that a little bit.
Oh, gosh.
Yeah, we were out there together for a few years,
and that was an awesome time on Oahu.
And we had a professor
that was the Hawaiian studies professor.
We both studied, now part of what we both studied
was cultural anthropology.
Was part of, I guess, what he ended up studying.
And then, yeah.
So we had some classes that we were together.
Yeah, there was definitely, or components
of that belief system that just really made a lot of sense.
And I think some of it had to do with our upbringing,
but this notion that, one of the strong ones
was this relationship that we have with the natural world,
with the earth and there's a belief
within a traditional Hawaiian belief
that if you are steward of the land,
if you protect the earth and you care for the earth,
that the earth has a moral obligation
to care for you in return.
And I wish I understood it better,
but I feel there is a definitely is a connection,
and there's a sense of,
there's some type of reciprocal relationship that exists
where not just in that, well,
that respiratory relationship that we have with the earth.
I mean, that's incredible to think about that.
That we consume carbohydrates,
and we breathe in oxygen and we drink water.
And that the combination of those three things
creates CO2 and energy.
And then we breathe out that CO2,
and the plants breathe in that CO2.
Right.
And they create carbohydrates and oxygen,
and breathe that back out.
And I feel as though there's something else that exists
that are somehow our connection with the natural world
and moving through the natural world,
whether it's walking or running or cycling
or swimming or surfing, whatever it is.
The emotions that we store absorb from,
I've always absorbed people's emotions around me.
And that gets heavy, that gets really heavy.
And running has become, it was always an outlet.
It was always a way to metabolize that emotion
and somehow breathe it back into the natural world.
And it felt as though there was something
within that natural world that I wasn't,
it wasn't a toxin that I was admitting.
It was almost as though it was something
that was beneficial somehow, and.
Right, the more that you grow and mature
and metabolize all of this, whatever you're aspirating out
is providing sustenance to something, yeah.
Yeah, and the reason that I feel that
is because I can go out and I can spin my wheels
and go through the motions in a densely populated city,
and I don't feel that release,
I don't feel as though it's metabolizing the same way
as if I was in in the mountains or in the canyon
or these hills around here.
I mean, that's what I love about.
What I love about here
is that you can be in such a densely populated area,
and then you just move.
Just next door is this rugged wild mountain,
and you have the ability
to exhale all of that that you've absorbed.
Anyway, it goes back to the, I guess,
the things that we learned there
when we were in school there,
and just that this understanding that there is a connection,
that there's a reciprocal connection,
not just between us in the natural world,
but between ourselves and other human beings, and.
I feel like that's heightened in Hawaii.
There is a real, palpable sense.
It's very experiential when you're there,
because there's a lot of light,
but there's a lot of dark there.
There's a polarity that exists for some reason.
Maybe it's on some Meridian.
I don't know what's going on there,
but I mean, it's real as far as I can tell.
Yeah, absolutely.
But the trick is then to come back to the main land
where it's less pronounced
and maintain that kind of reverence
and respect and awareness.
Yeah, and the one thing that I,
well, not the one thing,
but one thing that I do love about being out there
is that the currency out there
is service to the people around.
Right, I mean, that's where I was driving at
with this idea of ha.
Right, exactly.
Yeah, I think about the word inspire.
Inspire means to breathe life into something
the same as that notion of ha,
conspire to breathe life into something together
with somebody else and just that sense
that you have the ability as a human being
to positively or negatively affect the people around you,
based off of the way that you choose to interact
and our purpose, if there's a purpose,
our purpose for being here it's to serve each other
is to try to make the life of another individual easier
to try to help them on their way
to try to somehow be of assistance.
And there's this notion, this need for cooperation
and coordination that we have as human beings.
It's existed for hundreds of thousands of years.
But in the last couple of centuries
we've become more individualistic,
we've become more isolated rather than working together
with individuals cooperating in a tribe setting.
There's something uniquely American about that
because of the way we over prioritize
and over index and kind of Harold
the idea of rugged individualism,
which is really an illusion,
like nobody gets anywhere without cooperation and help.
But for some reason, we celebrate this idea
of the self-made man and these sort of principles upon
which our country was built.
Really look to that idea of individualism
as something that stands above all these other kind of ideas
that I think we should be celebrating
probably a little bit more
And as a result, we're isolating ourselves from each other
and we're not raising our children in a village
and we don't know our neighbors
and we consider it a weakness to ask for help.
And all of these things I think are really denigrating
the quality of our lives.
Yeah, absolutely.
Rather than focusing on coordination and cooperation
and receiving the reward that comes from that,
which is this production and distribution of oxytocin,
we use our consumption and accumulation
to feed that same need.
And we isolate ourselves and we get our validation
through our devices.
Right, or we only conspire and cooperate
in order to get to place where we can consume more
and separate ourselves from our brothers and sisters.
(laughs)
I'm sure you have this same experience,
but we originally met because we were both
with James the Iron Cowboy on the final day
of his 50, 50, 50,
and we got to run a few miles together
and that was super fun.
And one of the things I remember about that experience
was you being not just a cheerleader,
you were there to serve, like you're running back and forth.
You're making sure everybody's okay.
You're making sure James is okay.
And I was very aware of kind of,
I was very conscious of the intentionality
that you brought to that experience
in that it was all about making sure
it was the best day ever for James, right?
Yeah.
And it was, and it was amazing.
And I'll never forget that day.
I went back to on two occasions to participate
in his latest crazy adventure, conquer 101,
that's what you call it, right?
And one of the things,
set aside the sheer athletic achievement,
the thing that was most meaningful to me
was seeing this whole town turn up to support this guy,
like a small little town, not really a suburb,
like it's far enough away from salt lake
that it's kind of its own place with its own community.
And everybody showed up to support this guy.
And all these people flew in from all over the place
to support this guy.
And it was the most kind of cooperative situation.
And in some ways, kind of a throwback to a different time,
because it's a place where kids ride their bikes
down the street and everybody says hello to each other
it's a very leave it to beaver kind of town, right?
Yeah, absolutely.
And I was like, wow, this is kinda nice.
I live in LA, I don't see this anywhere, right?
But it is that spirit of cooperation
and a sensibility around kind of giving of yourself
or something greater than yourself.
Yeah, and its been a-.
And I know you went out there for I think I went out there
on the last day and James was telling me
that you had been out there,
I think a couple of days prior.
Yeah, I got there in New Jersey.
So I think the second half of maybe the last like 25 or so.
Right on the 50, yeah.
I mean, you were there for a huge long stretch,
but I mean the latest thing you were out,
you came out for a day.
Yeah, if I was my dad and my sister,
and we went out to see him.
Gosh, that's incredible.
There's not even words.
What do you even say about it?
Well, yeah.
And James is, gosh, his ability to,
just exactly what we were talking about earlier,
the potential that we have as human beings
to explore those outer ragged edges of that human capability
and to do it in a way that just empowers other people
to realize what it is that we're actually capable of,
to rewrite those rules and the way that he is able to do it
is through that cooperation and coordination.
Excuse me, to see how, it is an equal distribution of effort
by him and Sunny and the kids.
Sure, and he's the first person to make sure
that everybody understands that this is a team.
Yeah, exactly.
The wing man are unbelievable.
Yeah, they are, gosh, yeah that's a good crew.
I mean, that's a solid group of people
and you can't help but walk away from that
and be just inspired by, you know what I mean,
the same way that I mentioned
that it breathes life into you,
it helps you realize what you're capable of
as a human and not just what James has done,
but just like the way that we can rally around any cause
whatever it is.
And even not just the outward things that are said,
but just observing it, just watching it,
just seeing how it plays out and doing it so transparently
and openly like that to where everybody sees
there's no curtain that separates behind the scenes
in the front stage.
Everybody is just right out there
and you see all of it and you realize how much it takes
to be able to pull something like that off.
And that makes it even more inspiring
just that you can create something like that,
a community, a tribe, a family, whatever it is.
You have a goal and then you figure out a plan
and then you just chip away at it until you get it.
I know.
It's pretty incredible.
In your case, so much of who you are,
so much of your identity is that of the athlete, right?
And now obviously you have to recalibrate that whole thing.
How has that been for you
and how do you think about that?
Oh man, in my head it doesn't change.
I've had the opportunity to be around
a lot of really, really great athletes
living in Flagstaff working and being a body mechanic,
basically working on bodies, studying physical therapy,
studying massage, studying manual therapy,
you have the opportunity to be around
and put your hands on lots of really incredible athletes.
And it's really good because it helps you realize
how remarkable you are, you know and you go to Flagstaff,
you learn really quick that you're a tiny fish
in an enormous pond.
Oh, there's Ryan Hall or Sarah Hall.
There's Scott Falls.
Exactly, yeah, even on the buildups
where I was in the very best shape of my life,
there are three dozen males and females
that could kick my ass on any distance, in any event.
And I was just never going to be the greatest.
I was never going to be a great, great athlete.
I like to do everything that I could to wring out
my own potential, but I was very, very aware
that I was never going to be,
I'm not built to be a distance runner.
Sure, but at the same time, there's that,
there's the kind of performance outcomes
of being an athlete,
but more importantly or more meaningfully
is just the experience of being an athlete.
Like I get to go out and run these trails
and I can feel a certain way and run these distances
and connect with my breath.
And all of that, that gives us sustenance, right?
Is suddenly not available to you.
I guess what I was getting at is that it is still,
it's just different.
And it's just the thing that drew me to it was always,
be a part of that community,
being able to feel a part of, there's this cohesion
that takes place when you're out suffering alongside people
and training towards something and working collectively
towards something.
And my body is wrecked.
It likely won't ever be able to recover fully,
but I can still get out.
Yeah, I was gonna ask you like what can you do?
What does it look like?
Well, it's a lot of walking right now,
especially in Flagstaff at that elevation
and I'll get out and just slowly move.
And just that process of moving through the natural world,
it still provides the same.
I would have never loved, it's fun to compete,
but I really have always done it as a way of just being able
to work through my own issues.
It's this meditative reverent practice
of going out and I guess seeking
this transcendental experience and you become
so dependent upon it,
you have to make a lifestyle out of it eventually,
otherwise it gets flagged as something that's an addiction.
It's self destructive.
Let me just shroud all of this
and tell everybody it's a career.
If you can do that, but that's what it is.
That really is otherwise it becomes,
something that people say you should probably reconsider.
I remember I was talking to my dad a couple of years ago,
and my dad is like my best friend.
We talk on the phone like almost every day.
I was out on the same road, the same road that I run
back and forth day after day after day.
And I think it was like the third run of the day,
just because I'd had to break it up
and I was getting ready for a marathon.
And I'd been living in Flagstaff for, I dunno,
maybe six years and pursuing that full-time
and he said, "Wow, you're running again here,
you're the end of this running thing actually.
I was like, "Yes, dad."
It's something that I am pursuing a little bit seriously.
And I was like, dad, that'd be like, if I said to you like,
oh, you're still reading books.
Oh you're really into reading thing aren't you?
Still writing in your journal?
Yeah, exactly, yeah.
It's changed, it's different, it's slower,
but gosh, if we got to the end of this life
and if there was some kind of sit down judgment,
reconciliation, and the only thing that you had to show
for it was how fast you could run, what a waste of a life
that would be.
It's like, well, what did you do?
It's like, well, did you see how fast I could ran,
did you see how fast I could run a marathon?
And that is a pretty pathetic existence, you know?
There's nothing more self-serving than that, you know?
And so yeah, I don't know, who knows.
I don't know if I'll ever run that fast again.
I mean you've shared on Instagram,
you were out in the canyon with your daughter,
so you're getting out there in your own.
Yeah, I get out and move and that's as good as it gets,
being able to be in the canyon with Harper.
She's 11, she's incredible.
She says things that the way that she's connected
to the natural world it's unlike anything
I've ever experienced, we're walking and she said.
She said, "Dad, it sounds like the way that,
you know when you lick a rock?"
And I said, "What?"
She goes, "It's the sound of licking a rock,
but not like a river rock and not a piece of limestone,
like a piece of sandstone.
Do you know that sound that it makes
when you lick a piece of sandstone?"
And I was like,
"I know exactly what you're talking about."
That kinda.
There's the poet, that's amazing.
No, I was just like, wow.
That's so in tune.
Right.
Having experiences like that with her.
And does she like shame, somebody had like a boom box
or something like that down in the canyon.
And she was like, just not into it.
Yeah.
She just shook her head she goes, oh, noise pollution.
And I was like, yeah.
And it wasn't even to me, it was just to herself
and I just heard it.
And I was like, man, that's awesome.
That's a really proud moment.
Then she said something to me and it reminded me
of something that maybe I had said to her at one point,
but she said it back to me as though
it was an independent thought
I could tell it was like something that was a part of her,
but I was having a hard time coming back out,
we're hiking back out.
And gosh, I swear the canyon got wasted
for the last year and a half.
I'm coming back out and she's like, hey, you know what?
It's okay, like, it's okay.
Sometimes the memory is a lot better
than when we're actually living the experience.
And I was like, gosh, this kid.
Children are our teachers, Tommy.
That's unbelievable, wow.
To be able to have that experience.
And the fact that I can do that now,
be able to walk down there with her
and be able to walk in the trails just around her home
and sit outside and play with the ducks
and the chickens and just all of that.
It's like there's nothing better than that.
And I have that now, I remember a year ago,
a year and a half ago, bartering with whoever it is,
that is in charge of all of this.
Just let me get through this year,
just give me one more year.
If I can have a year, and then I'll gladly go
and I've made it, it's been a year.
Gosh, and then you get selfish.
You're like, okay, five more, 20 more, 50 more.
'Cause we're humans, man, right?
Yeah, exactly,
but it doesn't get any better than this.
It really doesn't.
And I mean, the tragedy is that we don't see it
until afterwards, you know?
I've been thinking about people say like,
and they lived happily ever after,
the operative verb there is lived.
They were alive and that's why it was happily ever after
then they died and it becomes a cooking tragedy
life is incredible.
As bad as it seems, as hard as it seems,
it's just such a gift to be able to do it.
And we talk about how tragic it is when something happens,
when somebody dies, somebody gets sick,
there's an accident, there's a disaster.
And as though that's out of the norm and in reality,
the fact that we're alive, it's just a miracle.
The fact that we're here,
it becomes really hard to talk about this stuff
because you can't express it in ways
that haven't been expressed in just such cliche terms
but the fact that we're living and breathing
and talking and all of this,
with everything that's going on.
On a space rock, yeah exactly,
that emits oxygen that we can breathe.
And we give it back CO2 as we're hurdling through space.
I mean, it's all insane, right?
That spinning 16.
But our brains can't really grok that whole thing.
Obviously we intellectually understand
like that life is a miracle,
but we can't fully embody that or appreciate that
on a moment to moment basis.
And in my experience, people who have experienced
certain types of trauma or life altering
situations like yourself come out of those experiences
with obviously this renewed appreciation,
but there's kind of a timeline, that dissipates over time.
It's hard to hold onto that, right?
And so here you are a year later,
I feel like you really are holding onto that.
you really are in the moment,
when we first sat down and you're like,
it's great man, I'm so happy.
I could feel it, that's real.
And I think an incredible gift for all of us
to hear you express that for you to fully embody that.
And a powerful reminder of just how precious all of this
is and how fleeting and how delicate and fragile.
Yeah.
I want a piece of that.
I wanna feel that on a soul level,
in the way that you feel it.
The lucky part is that as good as things are
they'll get bad again for all of us.
Right.
I guess the key is to not waste that suffering
when it comes, see it as a gift, see it as an opportunity
to open our eyes and to be able to value what it is
that we have.
Just a normal day,
just realizing how incredible that is.
And the tragedy is that we don't recognize it
until after the fact, but everything it's so cyclical,
everything that is good at anytime we're having a good time,
a comfortable time, life is good.
We can be 100% guaranteed that it's going to get bad again,
and as bad as it is, it can be 100% guaranteed
that it's going to get good again,
and it's just being able to see all of it all at once
and recognize what is good and be able to really value it
as it's happening.
Because like I was saying, there is no idealistic future
where it's gonna all be right.
And we're just going to be happy.
Happiness isn't something, we're not a victim of it.
It doesn't just happen to us.
It's happening all the time and it's our ability to see it
and recognize it.
And yeah, it's just incredible, really.
I had so many other things I wanted to talk to you about,
but I can't imagine a better way to end it.
And with that, it was so beautifully put.
Thanks, man.
You're a beautiful man.
I really appreciate you coming here today, I really do.
It's moving for me just to be in your presence
after having kind of closely followed everything
that's occurred in your life.
And I just have so much reverence and respect
for you, yes as an athlete,
but really just as a human being,
like the way that you comport yourself,
the way that you interact with the world,
the way that you are as a family man,
as a husband and as a father, I think it's really exemplary.
And I just have a huge amount of respect for you.
And I wish you well, man, I'm here for you,
for whatever you need man.
And I'm just delighted that we got to spend
a couple hours together.
Gosh, thanks, Rich, thank you so much.
I did want to point out before we close this up,
a couple of things, the first is you have this go-fund me.
It's still up there, right?
People can still contribute to that.
You don't even know.
Yeah, I think you can.
You guys have raised a bunch of money,
but medical bills are expensive.
So I'm going to link up that in the journals for people
who want to learn a little bit more about that.
And also you're a long time ambassador of Craft, right?
And this is really cool.
They came up with this,
they have this team Rivs collection, right?
But inspired by your experience,
they've decided to provide the US a discount
on their gear until the US gets universal health care.
You know about this, right?
Oh, yeah.
So they're giving 10.7% off,
which represents the amount Swedish citizens pay
of their income to cover healthcare,
which I thought was really cool and clever.
I think that was a recent announcement, right?
It was just a couple days ago.
Yeah, they're an incredible company.
It's been, Swedes just do everything better,
it's a Swedish company,
been around since I think since the 1970s,
they started with creating ski gear
in the cross-country skiing and then got into cycling
and getting into running and just having the chance
to work with them.
I started to work with them and we started to collaborate
on creating a shoe and creating some gear.
And it was right after I started with them that I got sick.
And man as far as our contract was concerned,
they had every right to terminate the contract
because my job was to basically be an athlete
and to collaborate on research and development
of these different products that we were creating.
And I wasn't able to do any of that at the time.
And they not just stayed with me,
but like doubled down and supported me and my family
and have gone on to create this entire line of clothing.
And man, it just speaks volumes as to the kind of company
that they are.
And it's cool.
It's been great.
Yeah, that's important.
And I don't think it was necessarily in response to me,
but it was just more in response to just the idea
that they wanted to provide that too.
Well, it definitely was in response to you.
You catalyze that thing.
It's cool, I think that it's cool that they're doing it.
Also I should point out for all you, iFit people.
You've got like a ton of stuff on the iFit platform, right?
You've gone all over the world running all over the place.
So there's all kinds of content in that platform.
Yeah, I had an opportunity to do that for a lot of years
before I got sick and there's a lot of stuff out there.
It's been a really cool experience to be able to do that.
And that was something that kinda kinda took off
when I was asleep too.
Just the support that came together from iFit,
from that community has been just mind blowing honestly.
Yeah, it's been really, I appreciate it.
Yeah, cool, man.
Well come back and share with me some more.
Can you do that?
Yeah, absolutely.
Everybody should definitely check out Tommy
on Instagram as well at tommy_rivs
and anything else before we sign off here?
Oh, just, thank you to everybody for all of this.
I wish I had better words in bigger words.
Oh man, it was beautiful, man.
All love brother, all love.
Thank you Rich.
All right, talk again soon, peace.
Bye.
(upbeat music)